Let's look at some examples
from the exercises of Cannes Academy,
to get used to different ways
to collect numbers.
The condition is, "Choose all ways,
which can be used to collect 78 and 9.
Choose all applicable ways. "
The first option is 77 plus 10.
But does that make sense?
Instead of 78, a 1-digit number is written,
that is 77 and instead of 9
a 1-digit number is written, say 10.
So it makes sense.
If you draw 1 unit of 78, but add that 1 unit to 9,
you will get the same amount.
This will be the same as 78 plus 9.
Therefore, this is true, this is the correct answer.
In fact, this is a good way,
because it is easier to calculate.
Because now you get 77 plus the nice circular number 10.
And you will just increase the titles by 1
and will get 87.
It's a little easier to calculate than that here.
But what happened here? Collected 7 and 8.
Why collect 7 tens plus 8 units?
Here they looked at the figure 7 as 7 units,
but that does not make sense.
That is why I choose only the first opportunity.
Let's take a few more examples.
"Choose any way that can be used to collect 35 and 15.
Choose all applicable ways. "
Here are collected 35 plus 5 and then added 10,
15 is decomposed to 5 and 10,
which makes sense because 15 is 5 plus 10.
And this is a good way, because here we get 40,
which we can calculate in mind,
and then add 10 to get 50.
Yes, this is a good way.
But what is going on here? 30 plus 20.
Here, instead of 35, recorded 30,
ie 5 units less.
Then the second number is increased by 5 units.
Taking 5 out of 35, you get 30.
When you add 5 to 15, you get 20.
Yes, it also makes sense and is also a good strategy,
because 30 plus 20, that's 3 decades plus 2 tens,
and is equal to 5 tenths, or 50.
It's very easy to think. It happened when
we took 5 units out of 35 and added them to 15.
Indeed, there is a lot of logic in it.
Let's figure out another example.
"Choose all the right ways to find the sum of 41 and 52.
Choose all the right ways "
Collect 40 plus 52 and then add 1 unit.
Let's think, 41 plus 52.
40 because we pulled out
1 unit of 41
and we will add it later.
Number 52 is not changed, so
41 plus 52 is the same as
40 plus 52, plus 1.
We just add that 1 unit later
and that's easier because
first collect only the decades,
40 plus 52 is 92, and when you add 1, you get 93.
Now let's see this opportunity. 43 plus 50.
Note that 2 is added to 41 and 2 is subtracted from 50.
Yes, that makes sense.
Add 2 here and get it out of here,
so that the same value will be obtained.
We'll get 93 again.
And this way is useful because it turns
52 in a nice round 50
by subtracting 2 units and adding them to 41,
to give 43.